[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'hebdo une
émission pour revenir sur l'actualité
départementale de la semaine voici les
titres de ce vendredi 30 juin des
entrepreneurs chinois et français réunis
à vélizy villacoublay pour l'aménagement
durable des quartiers d'affaires de
nombreux invités et des deux pays
étaient présents le temps d'une soirée
pour évoquer cette thématique et aborder
les partenariats en cours
pauline vino cours le fèvre est notre
invité fil rouge pour cette émission
conseillère départementale et vice
président délégué aux ruralité nous
évoquerons avec elle la fusion entre les
départements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine qui s'accélère et les
inquiétudes parfois exprimées par les
élus sur la ruralité enfin dans le reste
de l'actualité locale retour sur le
début de l'open de france de golf est
une première nationale avec une clinique
réservé au traitement de l'arthrose de
la main et qui ouvrira ses portes dans
quelques semaines à montigny le
bretonneux faire des quartiers
d'affaires des zones de développement
durable versailles grand parc vélizy
villacoublay et de nombreuses
entreprises françaises et chinoises y
réfléchissent depuis trois ans
maintenant
un colloque s'est tenu cette semaine
pour faire le point sur les avancées et
les opportunités
les précisions avec mélanie poké
respecter l'environnement tout en
développant les activités
une nouvelle parc sur
vélizy-villacoublay se développent en ce
sens un projet porté par la commune
versailles grand parc et l'afnor but
c'est de faire un grand réseau est de
faire que on participe à la croissance
économique et à la création de valeur de
notre pays mais au niveau de l'europe et
au niveau du monde avec les bonnes
démarches et faire en sorte que le
citoyen s'y retrouve que la planète s'y
retrouve et que la croissance de notre
économie soit trop tôt pour penser ce
projet deux modèles chinois basé à pékin
et à jean al de futurs sayan ce parc de
pékin fondé en 2009 est un projet
d'ingénérie scientifiques et
technologiques et vise 100 mille
personnes bien il y en a de javel a créé
notre parc le futur science park à pékin
un positionnement très très proche de
l'eee novell parc vélizy il est dans
notre intérêt de partager avec des
lisiers de continuer dans une bonne voie
de l'innovation
vous avez conscience 1100 grandes
entreprises sont aujourd'hui installés à
lille nouvelle parquet on peut à près de
cinquante mille personnes des
entreprises qui participent à la
conception du quartier d'affaires est ce
le début d'une fracture ou un désaccord
sans répercussions pour la majorité de
droite à saint quentin en yvelines hier
les élus de l'agglomération étaient
réunies pour le dernier conseil
communautaire avant la pause estivale
sans thème majeur il aura vu tout de
même des tensions apparaissent entre les
maires de villes pré villepreux et les
clayes-sous-bois à propos de la révision
du plan local d'urbanisme de la première
cité le maire des clayes-sous-bois
véronique côté millard a voté contre
cette révision provoquant la colère de
son collègue qui a dénoncé notamment un
manque de solidarité est une première au
sein de la majorité
dans le reste de l'actualité évidemment
le décès ce vendredi matin à 89 ans de
simone veil ancien ministre de la santé
rescapés de la shoah est connue bien sûr
pour avoir porté le projet de
légalisation de l'avortement au milieu
des années 70 à saint quentin en
yvelines
la faculté de médecine porte son nom
vous voyez d'ailleurs quelques images
lors du passage de l'ancienne présidente
du parlement européen a la faculté
c'était en décembre 2012 pauline vinocur
lefebvre bonsoir vous êtes conseillère
départementale des yvelines
une réaction déjà peut-être sur la
disparition cette triste actualité
simone veil qui est décédé ce vendredi
matin est ce que vous en tant que femme
politique ça vous évoque quelque chose
de particulier simone veil oui moi je
suis extrêmement peiné en tant que femme
et en tant que petite fille de déporté
aussi parce que
parce que c'est un pan de cette mémoire
vive qui disparaît avec elle est
évidemment en tant que femmes parce
qu'elles apportaient un texte de loi
essentiel et
et qui continue à faire parler de lui
aujourd'hui s'est jamais totalement
acquis et
voilà c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
continuer à défendre je suis extrêmement
peiné du décès timan vous étiez ce matin
au conseil départemental pour pau pour
la séance
il ya une minute de silence je crois de
la part des conseillers c'est important
de tous et revenir dans ce moment-là et
de et de rendre hommage c'est exactement
c'est exactement ça c'est une façon de
rendre hommage à une femme absolument
exceptionnel que j'ai toujours beaucoup
admiré je suis vraiment très peinés bon
elle était âgée elle était malade mais
mais c'est un pan de mémoire qui
qui s'en va avec elle alors ce conseil
départemental vous a permis aussi à une
large majorité l'on revient des affaires
beaucoup plus local de voter en faveur
de la fusion entre le département des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine les élus
du conseil départemental du 82e ont fait
la même chose ce matin la décision est
désormais entre les mains du
gouvernement
concrètement on pourrait voir le
département des yvelines dans ses
frontières actuelles disparaître quand
est ce qu'il ya un calendrier qui est
arrêté est ce que en 2018 on pourrait
les yvelines comme on les connaît les
voir disparaître est-ce que vous avez
des informations et à contrario les
hauts-de-seine tels qu'on les connaît on
pourrait les voir disparaître
j'ai pas d'info sur le calendrier ça
comme vous l'avez rappelé ne dépend plus
de nous alors vous le disiez les
hauts-de-seine mais justement se pose la
question quand on parle de cette fusion
quel sera le numéro du futur département
puisque c'est quand même important c'est
les gens les gens font seulement souvent
ce rapprochement sur les sur les
départements et puis le nom est ce que
vous avez des pistes vous avez des
bruits de couloirs qui ne s'alimente pas
absolument rien sincèrement aucune
information là-dessus je le dis du coup
quand on en sera au choix du nom
oui c'est qu'on aura bien évolué et que
les choses ont pris un angle favorable
donc on n'en est pas encore là et je le
disais cette fusion est donc entre les
mains du gouvernement
supposons que le gouvernement refuse
cette fusion est ce que tout continuera
comme avant est ce qu'on restera quand
même dans cette dynamique de
rapprochement même s'il y aura pas de
fusion du coup entre les deux
départements
la musique est la dynamique de
rapprochement a vocation à nous faire
faire des économies donc aux deux
départements donc
il n'y aurait aucune raison de ne pas
poursuivre mes
c'est quelque chose à laquelle vous vous
préparez le refus ou alors vous pensez
que vous allez avoir un apport positif
on espère un accord pin pour faire un
peu de pédagogie peut-être sur cette
fusion rappelez-nous éventuellement et
pour les habitants les avantages d'une
telle fusion
quel serait pour les habitants les
avantages de voir cette fusion actée
dans l'est dans les yvelines le
l'avantagé est essentiellement financier
en se rapprochant avec les
hauts-de-seine c'est un choix de
mutualisation et de rassemblement de
deux départements le nôtre connaître des
difficultés financières beaucoup plus
importante que les hauts-de-seine en
raison de la fonction qui opéré sur nos
dotations sur notre dotation globale de
fonctionnement notamment
et alors qu'elle pousse et l'argent qui
est donnée par l'état aux collectivités
beaucoup de pertes pour les yvelines ces
dernières années donc cet avantage là
pour vous mais du coup quel avantage
pour les hauts-de-seine de semaine
prochaine et aux dizaines l'avantagent
de se rapprocher d'un département dont
il partage la notion de gestion
des finances des fonds publics et de la
chose publique
on aime nos deux départements sont sur
des logiques de soutien fort à
l'investissement et pas au
fonctionnement
en somme deux départements qui avons d
épeautre fonctionnement rapportés par
habitant à sebha est ce qui nous
pénalise d'ailleurs parce que nos marges
de manoeuvre dans les yvelines sont
extrêmement faible on peut plus on peut
plus réduire considérablement notre
fonctionnement parce qu'il est déjà très
très bas et on a on partage avec les
hauts-de-seine cette vision là ce que
doit être l'action publique une aide à
l'investissement pour créer de l'emploi
dans notre dans nos territoires de
l'activité dans nos territoires et
notamment aux territoires ruraux
alors certains certains se moquent un
peu et disent que c'est un mariage entre
riches parce qu'ils se trompent parce
que c'est abusé de dire ça c'est un
mariage entre riches le département des
yvelines est plus riche enfin light et
ne l'est plus aujourd'hui en tout cas
vous pouvez interdépartement bien géré
et qui a été pénalisé par pour sa bonne
gestion avec une baisse de dotation
extrêmement forte à laquelle s'ajoutent
des péréquations qui servent à les
soutenir les départements moins bien
géré et donc non c'est pas un
département riche que ce soit un
département agréable avec un foncier
élevé y compris dans certaines communes
rurales un patrimoine riche ça c'est
indéniable mais mais pour autant au
niveau de la structure départementale
c'est pas un département riche et c'est
un département qui connaît un certain
nombre de difficultés de difficultés
liées à l'emploi notamment comme comme
les autres départements
alors vous le disiez certains élus
s'inquiètent en tout cas pour la
ruralité certains élus s'inquiètent même
si le vote a été assez probant ce matin
ils s'inquiètent de voir éventuellement
le sud des yvelines urbanisé il regrette
aussi que ce sujet n'a pas été abordé il
y a deux ans au moment des élections
départementales
est ce que par exemple vous qui étiez
candidate évidemment pour ces élections
vous saviez qu'un tel projet allait voir
le jour
c'est un non seulement ne savait pas non
c'est pas non plus que l'état elles ont
fonctionné à ce point là on serait
contraint au début du mandat d'augmenter
fortement les impôts
locaux la taxe d'habitation comme on l'a
fait c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a pas
fait de gaieté de coeur
tous fait face a été un moment difficile
de prendre cette décision après des
échanges nourris
voilà tout ça on le savait pain et là
c'est possibilité de mutualiser de se
rassembler avec le département des
hauts-de-seine se présente et je crois
pas du tout que ce soit un danger pour
la ruralité et qu'on a eu à organiser le
sud du territoire s'est passé absolument
pas l'objet ce qui veut dire que
imaginons que demain le gouvernement
décide de redonner des moyens au
département des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine est ce que ça pourrait
remettre en cause si je prends votre
logique cette fusion puisque apparemment
c'est le principal facteur qui a poussé
là non parce que
les
le gouvernement est aussi dans une
logique de regroupement des
collectivités on a un millefeuille
très riche et
le fait de regrouper des collectivités
est quelque chose qui est tout à fait
dans la logique de ce qui doit être fait
donc indépendamment de ces facteurs qui
sont ceux qui nous pousse à le faire
rapidement on peut tout à fait continuer
mais mes jeux
on ne fait pas tellement d'illusions le
département d'état est engagée dans une
poursuite des baisses de dotations il ya
des déficits publics extrêmement élevé
et les collectivités vont être de plus
en plus ponctionnés donc le la situation
va pas s'améliorer demain alors la
fusion du coup de vent continuera de
trouver tout son sens alors nous étions
ce matin au conseil départemental je
vous propose d'écouter l'un des
opposants à ce projet le conseiller
départemental yves en valent ils
s'opposent principalement à la forme du
projet à écouter le président nous avait
annoncé que l'on prendrait le temps de
se rapprocher pas à pas de faire
l'évaluation de ce rapprochement au fur
et à mesure je constate aujourd'hui
qu'on a on n'a pas fait ce travail
normalement devait avoir une
concertation à l'automne on précipite le
pas moi je le regrette je pense qu'on
aurait pu avant de voter savoir quelles
seront demain les conséquences sur la
fiscalité
quelles seront demain les conséquences
sur l'aménagement du territoire
c'est vrai que ça va vite un peu quand
même on a découvert ce projet fin fin
2015 là on est on va dire mi 2017
ça fait un peu plus d'un an et demi est
ce qu'on pourrait pas prendre un peu
plus de temps peut-être faire de la
pédagogie auprès des auprès des
habitants nous les médias peut-être
qu'on est bien informé
là dessus puisque il ya souvent des
conférences de presse qui sera organisée
mais on n'est pas forcément sûr que ce
soit le cas des habitants est ce que
comme un peu plus de temps ce serait pas
né à castillon qu'on a prise aujourd'hui
n'empêche pas de faire de la pédagogie
parce que comme vous le rappeliez tout à
l'heure c'est la décision finale
maintenant est dans les mains du
gouvernement et on ne sait pas quand
est-ce qu'ils la rendra donc ça nous
laisse probablement un peu de temps pour
continuer à en parler et a travaillé sur
le sujet ensuite il ya eu des réunions
au cours desquelles on a pu en parler
c'est un sujet qui a été évoqué avec
on a eu des réunions le président bédié
s'est rendu sur l'ensemble des
territoires départementaux pour
expliquer pourquoi on se rapprochait
quel était le modèle de la métropole
et quel était l'enjeu de cette fusion
yvelines hauts-de-seine on vient
vraiment eu une information des maires
et des concertations et en marge des
assises le sujet aussi été évoquée sur
les sur les rayons conclure les assises
de la ruralité on va en parler dans
quelques instants juste pour revenir sur
cette problématique de la métropole est
métropole du grand paris qui comprend
évidemment paris et la proche banlieue
mais du coup pas les départements de la
grande couronne est ce que c'est pour
pour s'insérer dans ce projet là c'est
aussi pour soi pour pallier alors sois
rentrée soit contre balancer et ne pas
être à l'extérieur de tout le
développement de tout le développement
économique de toute la création
d'emplois et de tous les axes de
transport ça me semble quand même
important de pinceau qu'autant de
contenter de rester dans les prêts à
regarder passer les trains
alors il y a quelques jours pierre
bédier le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines a présenté un
plan pour améliorer le service au public
en milieu rural un plan qui fait suite
notamment aux assises de la ruralité
lancer fin 2015 en presque deux ans
maintenant vous êtes vous penchez
forcément particulièrement sur le
dossier quel constat vous tirer de vos
actions quels sont les manques des zones
rurales dans les yvelines quelles sont
les priorités que vous avez ciblé
alors les priorités restent celles qu'on
avait identifiées pendant et à l'issue
des assises de la ruralité on peut les
regrouper sous un terme qui est la
communication la communication avec
internet et
avec les transports qu'ils soient
routiers ferroviaires en partage etc
le haut débit ça arrive d'ici 2020
toutes nos communes seront équipés en
toutes les communes rurales
hors zone d'intervention des opérateurs
seront équipées en très haut débit
numérique donc ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour pour les communes rurales
est bon pour les transports certaines
décisions ne dépendent pas de nous mais
des twittos de la région si l'avenir et
par région de l'otan on continue à
travailler sur ces une piste qu'on n'a
pas encore complètement fini d'explorer
mais sur la possibilité d'aider au
covoiturage c'était un sujet qui avait
été très largement portée par les
habitants pendant les assises et après
un bon paquet d'autres mesures ont été
mises en oeuvre notamment le
renforcement du rôle de la ville de
rambouillet on peut dire qu'elle va
devenir la capitale officielle de la
ruralité
j'ai vu qu'on appelait capitaine de la
ruralité oui les
l'idée est d'avoir un territoire
d'action départementale unique pour
couvrir le secteur rural avec des
effectifs renforcés pour gagner en
efficacité et en réactivité et en
couverture du territoire du territoire
l'objectif de toutes ces actions aussi
et ça sera ma dernière question depuis
notamment les assises de la réalité
c'est de lutter contre ce sentiment
parfois justifié parfois erronées
d'abandon des zones rurales c'est ce
qu'il ya à la fois un sentiment
d'abandon est à la fois une certain
nombre de contradictions ou des
incompréhensions porté par les habitants
d
des zones rurales et je le dis sans
aucune critique
on a beaucoup de néo ruraux en fait qui
viennent s'installer à la campagne et
qui veulent le cas de reval le calme au
graal mais pas les contraintes de la
ruralité
en gros la réalité c'est bien au mois de
juin quand il s'agit de faire des
barbecues mois novembre
c'est un peu plus indiqué quoique au
mois de juin les tracteurs bloquent la
route et des agaceries matin alors qu'en
novembre décembre janvier ils peuvent
déneiger les routes et là ça arrange
tout le monde que c'est on met
constamment sur le v8 faut faire de la
pédagogie en salle les assises était un
exercice intéressant c'est important
d'en faire et je pense que le rôle des
élus locaux que les maires en première
ligne et le conseil département les
maires en première ligne des intercoms
en seconde ligne et conseiller
départemental en troisième ligne
c'est d'apporter les réponses qui sont
justifiées parce que évidemment on a
besoin d'augmenter l'offre d'accueil des
jeunes enfants dans les communes rurales
par exemple d'améliorer les réseaux et
et de continuer à faire de la pédagogie
pour expliquer que certaines
certains services qu'on peut avoir en
projet d'un lieu où qu'ils soient
certains dont la mission impossible mais
pour autant notre rôle c'est aussi
d'apporter un certain nombre de réponses
pour que les habitants ne semblent pas
délaissés et se sentent pris en compte
dans leurs communes rurales pauline
vigne au court lefebvre rester avec nous
on passe tout de suite à l'actualité de
la semaine
une actualité politique forcément avec
la première séance de l'assemblée
nationale en présence des députés des
yvelines les différents postes clés ont
été également réparties entre les
groupes parlementaires cette semaine au
sein de la république en marche
aurore bergé élus de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines a été
désigné porte-parole du gouvernement
écouter à sa réaction je serais content
parce que j'avais déjà cette mission
pendant la campagne présidentielle qui
était de confronter la parole du
candidat le maquereau et je suis très
heureuse de croire aujourd'hui porter la
parole du groupe
et voilà je très heureuse qu'il m'ait
fait confiance pour le faire n'est ce
pas que je serai à la hauteur
on a on remettra ans
enjeu de différents postes à mi mandat
on n'est pas là pour durer pendant cinq
ans mais sur ces responsabilités là
deux ans et demi je serai l'une de
celles qui porterait la parole du groupe
paulino cours le febvre vous êtes une
jeune élue c'est votre deuxième mandat
celle de conseillère départementale vous
est également conseillère vous étiez où
vous êtes conseillère municipale vous
êtes toujours conseillère municipale
quel jugement vous portez sur c'est vrai
qu'on a un peu perdu en ce moment sur la
vague en marche qui a tout chamboulé
l'espace politique qu'en quelques
semaines et notamment les républicains
dans les yvelines on les a vus avec les
postes de député il n'en reste plus
qu'un dans le département comment vous
regardez ça vous quel est votre avis
là-dessus n'a comme vous dites on est un
peu perdu
j'attends de voir ce que ça va donner
certains certains s'inquiètent un peu de
l'hégémonie de la république en marche
de ce semblant de renouveau pour
certains est ce que vous vous trouvez ça
aurore bergé c'est pas du renouveau elle
est la minute puis alors elle et elle a
30 ans mais elle fait de la politique
depuis par l'enseignante avait monté
c'est extrêmement expérimenté donc oui
si c'est l'âge le sexe on peut
considérer que c'est du renouveau il ya
beaucoup plus de femmes à l'assemblée ça
on peut évidemment que le saluer
maintenant j'attends de voir ce que ça
va donner
c'est jamais illogique après une
élection présidentielle qui est une
vague enfin est souvent assez forte en
faveur de la majorité en place
voilà maintenant j'attends de voir ce
que ça va donner alors on parle beaucoup
de maquereaux compatible de constructif
en ce moment à titre personnel si vous
étiez députés on sait que c'est une
question qui divise la droite est ce que
vous seriez selon vous on fait de la
fiction mais ce que vous soyez plutôt
constructif ou opposition pure et dure
constructive on a tout intérêt à faire
avancer le pays dans le bon sens
maintenant il ya des mesures du
programme de macron qui était dans son
programme des présidentielles avec
lesquels je ne suis absolument pas
d'accord caché de république tient aussi
j'ai les républicains aussi mais la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation par
exemple je pense pas que ce soit une
bonne chose
justement on va terminer sur cette
question pourquoi puisque c'est un sujet
concernant vous êtes conscient latéral
soit les gens vont les administrés vont
être contents la première peut-être la
deuxième année on est ravi leur taxe
d'habitation va diminuer mais après les
communes vont bien devoir
panier le manque de financement pour les
états dit que ce sera pour compenser
totalement compensée mais en même temps
on dit ah nous dit qu'il va continuer à
baisser les dotations et généralement
quand une dotation est compensée elle
n'est pas compensée sur la durée en tout
cas pas la valeur qu'elles devraient
vraiment mauvaises surprises il y aura
forcément des mauvaises surprises et les
administrés qui seront contents les deux
premières années seront un peu moins
content quand leurs impôts locaux et
d'autres impôts locaux augmenteront ou
quand les tarifs des services publics
augmenteront voir quand les services
publics disparaîtront leur commune donc
je pense pas que ce soit une bonne chose
pour nos communes merci paul in vino
cours lefebvre d'être venu en plateau je
vous rappelle que vous êtes notamment
conseillère départementale
élu sur le canton d'aubergenville merci
à vous
dans le reste de l'actualité cette
semaine du golfe avec la 101e édition de
l'open de france qui se déroule jusqu'à
dimanche sur les greens de saint quentin
en yvelines
pour cette première édition sous le
pavillon du groupe d'investisseurs
chinois h année la compétition a attiré
des têtes d'affiché françaises comme
alexander levy au victor dubuisson et
des stars internationales aussi avec une
nouvelle dotation de 7 millions d'euros
le rendez vous a également intégré les
relègue series les meilleurs tournois
européens écoutez à ce propos le
président de la fédération française de
golf
jean-loup charron paris pour eux
capitale du rendement tisme et puis la
terre de golf perdre d'accueil de la
ryder dans un an et nous sommes-nous
fédération ravi de cette évolution
nous sommes ravis de cette montée en
puissance de notre peine nationale et
puis on croise les doigts pour ça se
poursuit dans l'aude tous les tentes du
terme plus propre plus pratique est
aussi plus écologique le bus 100 %
électrique devienne réalité en ile de
france un nouvel équipement va bientôt
rouler sur la ligne
trois du réseau kéolis entre versailles
et vélizy villacoublay
porté par la région cette initiative
s'inscrit dans le cadre du grand paris
des bus qui doit permettre de renouveler
30% de la flotte parisienne d'ici trois
ans elle les détails avec ce reportage
une première discrète et sans pollution
voici le bus 100 % électrique à petit ce
dès le mois de septembre les voyageurs
de la ligne 23 du réseau fébus pourront
emprunter ce véhicule innovant entre les
villes de versailles et vélizy
villacoublay
conçu par le spécialiste des transports
la société alstom s'est inspiré pour ce
prototype du modèle parisien des
tramways on a un concept quand je dis
tramway sur pneus c'est parce que vous
avez une structure mécanique qui nous
permet déjà d'installer tous les
équipements en toiture et pas d'en avoir
à la fois dans le jeu lui sous le
châssis on a également 25 % de surfaces
vitrées en plus par rapport à un bus
conventionnel donc on retrouvait là
aussi un petit peu l'image du tramway
et puis vous voyez pampilles à trois
portes donc trois portes aujourd'hui
tramway donc une meilleure accessibilité
puis surtout des des portes qui sont
beaucoup plus robuste que des portes de
bus lancé en 2016 par le syndicat des
transports d'ile-de-france les bus
électriques rentrer ici dans une
nouvelle phase avec au total six lignes
équipées en région cette nouvelle
génération de bus plus écologique et
plus confortables doit permettre aussi
de rendre attractif les transports en
commun pour les franciliens pour décider
les habitants de la grande couronne à ne
pas prendre leur voiture
il leur faut des transports en commun
qui soit attractive sa vie
avec l'air conditionné ça veut dire avec
de l'info voyageurs ça veut dire
totalement accessible quand on a des
enfants des poussettes ça veut dire ça
veut dire un autre bus et pour les
habitants de la grande couronne c'est
aussi important d'avoir des bus
silencieux et non polluant la région ile
de france s'est fixé comme ambition de
rendre propre 30% de sa flotte de bus et
de cars d'ici 2020 transport toujours et
c'est désormais officiel le prix du pass
navigo augmente une nouvelle fois il
coûtera 75 euros et 20 centimes à tous
les franciliens à partir du 1er août une
hausse que la région justifie par les 10
milliards d'euros d'investissements
prévus dans les prochaines années s 6
millions c'est le nombre de personnes
touchées par l'arthrose en france cette
maladie dégénérative peut devenir un
véritable problème au quotidien et
empêcher l'utilisation de certains
membres aujourd'hui la prise en charge
n'est pas toujours adapté en france le
docteur christian couturier spécialiste
de la main à trappes a donc décidé
d'ouvrir une clinique pluridisciplinaire
pour soigner cette maladie qui touche
principalement les personnes âgées en
établissement qui ouvrira ses portes
dans quelques semaines à montigny le
bretonneux les précisions avec camille
lambert tenir un objet se brosser les
dents des gestes du quotidien souvent
douloureux et parfois même impossible
pour les malades atteints d'arthrose de
la main mais pour le docteur christian
couturier chirurgien de la main à
trappes
ce n'est pas une fatalité il a décidé de
créer une clinique adaptée à la prise en
charge de cette maladie
on entend dire sans arrêt à nos
consultations que celles âgées qui a
rien à faire et malheureusement c'est
pas vrai il ya plein de choses pour
soulager les patients soulager la
douleur conserver la fonction c'est un
projet très innovant parce que à ma
connaissance il n'y a pas d'autres
établissements en france dédiée à la
prise en charge de l'arthrose de la main
et du membre supérieur dédié à une prise
en charge pluridisciplinaire et pluri
médecine et avec un protocole
d'évaluation de toutes ces prises en
charge un établissement polyvalent qui
regroupera différents spécialistes
médecin chirurgien mais aussi ostéopathe
acupuncteur ou naturopathe des médecines
alternatives bien connu du docteur
françois brouchoud cela fait trois ans
qu'il travaille en france et en chine
on a des hôpitaux ou en post opératoire
il n'y a pas de traitement allopathique
où on est sûr de la médecine
traditionnelle avec des traits vraiment
de médecine traditionnelle de
l'acupuncture les massages traditionnels
et les gens n'ont pas plus mal et ils
ont des chirurgies qui sont exactement
identique à la nôtre dans ne crée pas un
centre de médecine alternative pas du
tout c'est une c'est un centre pour
prendre soin du patient et chaque
patient d'avoir une affinité différentes
à des différents praticiens ou technique
et je pense que le point fort sa lettre
justement la collaboration entre de ces
différentes techniques et pas simplement
les opposer c'est de travailler en
collaboration
une première en france qui ouvrira à
montigny le bretonneux à l'automne 2010
est la clinique pourrait accueillir sept
à dix mille personnes par an six
millions de français sont touchés par
l'arthrose c'est la fin de ce set 8
l'hebdo merci de nous avoir suivis
retrouver tous nos reportages en replay
sur tv fil 78 points comme ou
l'application tv fil 78
bon week-end à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]